foreign
[Music]
there look
see is it broken no no look look daddy
fixed it no wait wait okay I'll give it
to you when you tell me where we are
first that's better that's right this
was Grandpa's house
here you want the camera
here take it nope
anyways
oh it's okay Caesar
I think Little Caesar's tired up on the
drive aren't you guys
why aren't there any curtains upstairs
in the middle of nowhere and no one's
watching okay hi Mommy hi June bug wait
a minute I thought this was broken
because please be careful I just don't
want it to break again
yeah we just want to make sure that we
don't break it again well then I'm just
gonna fix it again aren't I what's that
James
just the altitude
that is mine
[Music]
foreign
these two are gonna get through this I'm
here for you someday she'll understand
[Music]
okay
hmm
call June
oh my gosh mom Siri please time
well oh God can you please do me a favor
and clear your voicemail I've been
trying to leave you messages well
they're probably all from you you know
you don't have to use Siri for living
everything right listen I am running
late and I need you to write a couple of
things down the car keys are going to be
in the top drawer in the kitchen and
Kevin I just said write it down you're
not writing it down
Kevin boarded you the itinerary no
alcohol do not open the door for
strangers and keep your vocation service
turned on the entire time I'm away do
you understand no fun got it uh what
about for like you know like like food
or
food or whatever I left a key with
Heather just call her if you need
anything no what do you mean
whatever you need
I don't have your eights okay okay so
you pick Heather of all people you do
not understand the sacrifices I made to
get you man
you were telling me that
foreign
I just I just need to know that you're
safe when I'm away
all right Kevin's going to be there any
minute to call the Uber I also just
deposited some money into your account
for emergencies understand
what's the money for
emergencies
[Music]
wow
that cat just won't come around how's
the old uh computer running
oh yeah it's a little faster thanks no
problem what
uh it's a Colombian thing I'm working on
my Spanish
cool
um I know you're in summer vacay mode
but uh you have a sec
uh
how do I say this
look
I know that I'm just
I don't know the new guy to you but
I love your mom
and
I know I planned this for just me and
her but
it's for a very special reason
hey hey what's going on
no June and I were just chatting oh okay
did you call the Uber two minutes away
do you want to take the bags down
it takes 30 seconds to wheel to move
okay all right I'll see you out there
thank you
really
look I'm I'm sorry if it seems like I'm
hard on you
but it really is just to make sure
you're safe Uber's actually here okay
coming
June listen to me I I need you to pick
us up on Monday at LAX can you do that
yes ma'am thank you
Chris you hear me
[Music]
all right okay okay